Le malaise . "Sensation pénible , mal localisée, d'un trouble physiologique
Brusque défaillance des forces physiques pouvant aller jusqu’à l’évanouissement"
Oh pu*ain . "État, sentiment de trouble, de gêne, d’inquiétude, de tension"
Bienvenue dans
Essayez de ne pas être mal a l'aise 2
*générique*
Bonsoir et bienvenue sur MalaiseTV dans la première vidéo qu'on avait fait de ce genre
On était sur un compte Twitter qui en fait reprenait les vidéos de MalaiseTV
VILAIN GARÇON
Alors on va pas regarder les 50 vidéos qu'il a mis en ligne.
J'ai fait une petite présélection, en me basant sur le titre et la durée de la vidéo.
C'est parti, nous ne devons pas rire... Être mal à l'aise! PFFF Les deux les deux.
Voilà double challenge, qu'est-ce tu vas faire.
Ho nan, ça va arriver nan ça va arriver, nan ça va arriver. NANNNNN
Le mec a pas le temps de comprendre
HAHA ! Le mec réfléchit qu'est-c'qui se passe.
nan NAN !
Nan nan.
Mettez-le en PLS ! Mettez-le en PLS !
Position latérale de SECURITÉ !
METTEZ-LE EN PLS ! Mon gars le cauchemar de ouf !
Mais c'qui est extraordinaire dans l'histoire c'est qu' le mec à la sono il lance quand même du Bruno Mars.
*musique de Bruno Mars*
*rire*
J'suis hyper désolé pour ce mec il m, i, iiii c'est horrible .
''Quand un stagiaire croit qu'un journaliste lui parle.''
Ah ça sent le bon vent ça.
Le mec qui interwiew : euh, les peintures de cartes qui en ont achetés
euuh des couches sur la dernière semaine ?
Le mec en costard : On peut très bien faire ça oui.
Le mec qui interwiew : Et qu'est-ce qui sort du coup c'est des lignes...
Re : des couches sur la dernière semaine ?
Re : On peut très bien faire ça oui.
Re : Et que-ce qui sort du coup c'est des lignes... Euh... De chiffres ?
aaaaah
Ça me met pas mal à l'aise, mais j'ai presque rigolé quand même.
oouh, on n'était pas loin il a faillit gagner là ! Hein !
''C'est dur de boire ptdrr de lol, mariage''
Ils sont bourrés déjà c'est ça ?
WTF? - WTF?
On dirait un mariage forcé mec !
Jusqu'au bout ils ont du mal.
oh nonnnn !
oh non, mais ils sont stressés c'est leur mariage.
Nan c'est normal, c'est normal.Tranquille.
''Gros bide à l'hélium en boite.''
De l'hélium en boite, déjà y a un problème
La femme : J'ai trouvé le mec relou de la soirée salut !
Bonjour tout le monde ça vaaa ? Ça va la famille ?
Soirée ?? ça déchire,  POULEEEET
Attention attention !
euh bonjour ... HEIN HEIN HEIN
Ok pas génial mais bon ça passe.
oh la batârde ! Qui tu es pour juger des mecs bourrés qui s'amusent avec de l'hélium?
Et j'dit pas ça parc'que j'fais pareil !
''Un robot qui detek les mouches sur un cadav.''
Ah ça m'dit un truc ça !
Alors, une question. Oui oui, on vous donne le micro monsieur.
J'aurai voulu savoir est-ce que il est...
J'fais pause, j'suis sûr qu'elle va regretter cette décision. Déjà d'entrée d'jeu.
J'aurai voulu savoir est-ce que il a été mis au point un robot qui ''détek'' une mouche qui a été sur un cadavre ?
En campagne, et qui rentre dans les maisons, qui va sur du pain ou du beurre.
Elle est elle est vers...
HAHAHAHAHAAA !
Le mec il parle d'un robot qui détecte les mouches et la merde et ensuite qui vont sur du pain
Et la meuf tout ce qu'elle dit:
''Je vois pas où est l'interlocuteur.''
Il fallait tirer la poignée rouge qui auto-détruit le micro, je sais pas!
Qu'il soit détecté, le ver, s'il est... s'il est pas contaminé.
On entend plus parler que les ... Que les gens ils peuvent ce nous...
La dame: je vois pas qui parle
Arrête de combler le malaise en disant que tu ne vois pas ton interlocuteur.
Tout le monde se rend compte de la supercherie.
Le mec : Parce que y'a eu, y'a eu un problème...
Nan j'ai pas rigolé, ça comptait pas. Non mais c'est extraordinaire ce qu'il a dit, j'suis désolé.
Donc eux ils font un contre-débat, c'est comme en soirée t'sais y'a 3 mecs qui s'isolent qui font une contre-soirée.
Là eux ils font un contre-débat et le débat c'est juste : Où est le mec qui parle ?
J'avoue c'est pas con c'est le meilleur moyen de zapper complètement ce que le mec dit.
Qui est en train de parler pour qu'on ait l'air de vous répondre ?
Ah d'accord, pardon !
Il assume.
Alors non, tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'ya un robot je crois il me semble qu'il est japonais, mais j'en suis pas sûre.
(Comme tous les robots...)
Monsieur...Voyons, on pourrait philosopher pendant très longtemps sur, comment nous arrivent certaines remarques...
Et euh... notamment, je dirais une conception de la vie à avoir...Notamment
Et donc hum, hum commment dire ?
Sur le, alors... oui j'avais discuté en fait j'avais alors étant libriste de hum
Mais nan ! Mais nan ! Comment ces deux mecs peuvent se retrouver dans la même salle, au même endroit ? C'est pas possible.
Hum, donc hum, euh j'ai posé une question à hum, huum
à une salle, nan j'ai fait une remarque
Pffff HAHA
J'ai pas vu le mec à droite qui mobilise toutes les ressources de son corps pour essayer de comprendre ce que ce gars dit.
Ils sont créé un robot libre hun ? Au libre heuu on dit libre de droits mais c'est pas de droits qui faut dire effectivement. Et donc euh
C'est dur j'peux pas résister !
Et donc euh j'ai eu comme réponse euh
Ah ça y est, ça y est. C'est bon il est exaspéré, il a laché. Il a tout mobilisé pendant 20 secondes puis il en pouvait plus !
Huum
Y'a une question ?
La question c'est : Par rapport à Louis XVI pouvez-vous me parler de Turgot ?
(Rires)
Oh la chute, elle est ouf! Je kiffe ce mec !
D'accord ! On va enchaîner quand même !
Attendez, on peut pas vous entendre sans micro monsieur. Voilà
Est-c'qu'il a été mis au point un robot qui détecte l'abeille qui a été contaminée du pesticide ?
Qui, quand on la voit au sol, elle peut plus voler. Alors, donc ça veut dire quelque chose. C'est un signe.
Pour l'instant ça n'existe pas encore, pour l'instant ça n'existe pas.
Il a ramené ça sur le tapis, comment il a fait ? Personne n'a vu il a pris le truc il l'a ramené comme ça.
Oh c'était dur, c'était très dur.
''Le bide d'une fan de pokémon.''
Bon eh bas du coup il y aura un petit gage, alors toi tu vas devoir imiter le cri d'un Pokémon, celui que tu veux.
(Squeezie) Il dort, il est posé.
Et toi devras mimer un... tu te réveilles, on se réveille là dedans !
Il mime déjà, il fait Marisson!
Oh ça m'a épuisé ! J'pourrais plus jamais réussir à me concentrer autant pour éviter de rire.
Oh faut que je dorme, comme le mec au début de la vidéo. J'suis sûr il lui est arrivé pareil.
Elle avait déjà fait un bide, il a tout donné pour pas rire et il s'est endormi.
''Bonjoureuh''
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Jérôme tu nous fait un sketch ou quelque chose.
Ou tu te lâches un peu parce que là j'ai l'impression que tu y es pas quoi
Tu as les bras bringuebalant. T'es coincé, t'as pas le sourire. T'as pas l'oeil qui pétille, t'as rien.
Tu te tournes et quand tu te retournes, on veut voir quelque chose qui bouge, quelque chose qui mette la pêche.
Dans le registre que tu veux, mais on veut voir quelque chose qui déménage.
Allez vas-y !
EH BONJOUR
Vous allez bien ?
Vous avez pas l'air d'aller bien là.
Vous répondez pas ?
Pourquoi ?
Il me faut de l'air, il me faut de l'air, il me faut de l'air !
C'est bon !
Put**n. Aujourd'hui c'était vraiment dur ! On a le droit d'en rigoler mais il faut pas aller harceler les gens non plus, hein.
J'sais qu'y en a qui derrière s'amuse à retrouver les gens, à les harceler, à se moquer, à se moquer tous les jours.
Ça, ça sert à rien, faut pas le faire. déjà ce qu'on fait là c'est un peu limite.
J'suis sûr que sur le dernier live qu'on a fait avec Mika, Yann, Cyprien etc..
J'ai forcément fait un bide à un moment
Et qu'un jour je me retrouverai dans une de ces vidéos horribles !
Allez à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé
Je vais rire pendant 10 minutes, là, une fois que j'aurai lancé l'outro.
J'ai besoin d'évacuer, d'évacuer j'vous dit !
Allez à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé.
Ciao tout le monde, peace !